[Music]
we watch shadow war have a much better
understanding of what it is Rob you
played a lot of shadow of mordor yeah
from your perspective of someone who
played a lot of that game back in 2014
what are you excited most about based on
the 16 minutes a game place from shadow
four uh the one thing that stood out for
me was you know at like the first game
you can recruit war Chiefs and such to
be on your side but this time around it
feels like you get to kind of see them
on the field and actually like watch
your your team that you've created your
yeah your warlike and fun fold that you
have basically shifted yourself yeah and
and the last game kind of had that it
was only in the last few moments right
where you actually have to see your your
entire game like unfold yeah when you
did this like storming they're like
these checker they're kind of these you
know like trees screens where you see
where your different lieutenants are
kind of ranking up where your spies are
and then how they're going to usurp the
next person now you're actually building
an army yeah I need to actually see it
in action opposed to guys and so long
since I played the shadow of Mordor
looking put it 2014 I think but you're
you know in that one you're kind of
looking at a menu the whole time and
you're seeing like a chess play of you
know figures moving around aboard now
you get to like see that on the
battlefield or obvious I hope so so the
60 minute gameplay video showed one of
these invasions into a fortress so there
are several fortunes oh here Sarah Goss
these are actual real camel stud real
women real middle-earth locations you
know you have Tirith on goal minutes
more go luckily if you have it looks
like based on the video keeps working
about I like lore the Rings I know but I
just love your memory for everything you
ever encounter you lure the Rings a lot
doesn't matter anything I throw you you
anyway yeah it looks like based on the
videos very end it looks like your
ultimate goal is to get to berried or
the tower were Sauron resides because
he's come back to power the premise of
the game is that pally and the ranger
and Kelly brim bore the elf who's famous
in the books
having crafted the ring of power you're
making your own and I don't know they
didn't really clarify whether the ring
with factoring into your abilities yet
at this point in the game but it looks
like the combat is still very much
intact from shadow Mordor it's that you
know kind of Arkham Asylum popularized
the attack encounter dichotomy of combat
but now the abilities they showed I
don't know if this was just later on the
skill tree for the purposes of this demo
but they were just executing people left
and right and my favorite one which we
might see I'll hold off actually I'll
wait so we're going to see it but you
like warping around you're shooting an
arrow and then warping to where the
arrow landed but I keep telling people I
don't if there are many XCOM fans but
this reminds me of
XCOM in the way that there's this
strategy layer above the meat of the
game kind of because you're still coming
in Fighting's combat and supposedly the
different regions of Mordor still have
these open worlds where you're exploring
and like Rob said you know you're doing
the Nemesis system and going to
different outposts taking control of
different lieutenants you know kind of
planting seeds for the you know interior
destruction of this battalion but then
later on you are actually like you can
see here assaulting these fortresses to
take over the regions and then build
your army whether it be through like
supplies or pillaging or getting new
recruits or war machines it's actually
the strategy layer of building your army
with the final endgame of getting to
Sauron and in here it looked like I mean
it look looks like you can recruit those
bigger ogres I know the name of Rome
trolls
thank you those guys clearly are you
know stronger and you can imagine hey
I'm going to use this troll to be my
frontlines
you know door Smasher mmhmm yeah that
shortly yeah and you know as you can
imagine if you lose him well shoot now I
got to go find another one of those guys
yeah like you are strategizing you're
your team and moving those pieces more
so or me not not at all from the first
game sure you all York's were generally
the saint's they just had you know
different personalities and when the
kind of you know procedurally generated
mhm yeah the other thing I think I'm
excited about what this is
now that I would ever want to be friends
with an orc but there's that option
right like you can kind of pick
favorites and and have them climb up in
the ranks and on the flip you know later
on in this demo that I thought was
really awesome was when you know you're
you're battling the end Overlord boss
and one of your buddies comes in and
save the day yeah it helps you out yeah
afterwards you have the option to
appoint him as the new overlord of the
stronghold or you don't
yeah and I and then this one and the
demo they did you know he's like hey
this guy saved my life I'm reward him
he's now overlord what if he didn't and
then later on as the game implies he
betrays you because you didn't oh I
wasn't fit to be a legal yeah second
number two Peter Campbell of shadow war
that's really cool to me and then later
on the game that was a cool part about
Nemesis system was look at that
reference oh I did your Campbell from
madman never mind yep you remember it's
non sequitur uh you know and then later
on this guy this betrays you yeah and
then he's like I know I'm the leader of
the other guys like yeah what's fight
yeah that's what Monell is there's like
a voiceover by someone that sounds
suspiciously like Kate Blanchet I don't
think it is it's not I don't know why I
said I don't think it is because I know
it's not but it sounds like her final
just reminds me of a voiceover intro the
beginning of fellowship and wrangling
Galadriel is like you know things are
changing whatnot but she says
specifically that there is you know
friendship is a major component of the
Nemesis system now right here I love
this assassination watch this taylean
comes out or no sorry Killebrew more
comes out of his body kills the other
one does this co-op takedown and then
goes back into his body then this one -
over here rink and then this is as
opposed to shooting an arrow and
spawning near the guy he does the flip
come to me oh yeah yeah that's what we
need
God is satisfying it is yeah - it works
head ii a lot going on this game or
Beckett or - I saw that I was like oh
yeah that's this game a surprise so I
you know based on stuff last week you
guys I didn't really play a whole lot of
the first one yeah but seeing this I now
want to go back and play that so they
haven't come into the
like yeah as armed as you guys are with
knowledge and excitement because this
does look really cool and I know outside
of this we're going to have the stuff
that was in the the core of the first
game and we can hope so yeah like this
seems like another one of those
experiences that is just different and
like meaningfully different in like a
big way yeah the whole you know angle
that that are trying to go for is that
they're expanding the Nemesis system to
not just be about these enemy leaders
but bam you have a spy that you've had a
few months in here and he's just
implanted and he happens to be a sniper
who saves you oh yeah cocky look at how
many things you immune to this crew
seems badass but also immune I think if
you're listening to the audio or when
you listen to audio I encourage you to
watch this gameplay video with audio
after lobby if you have not seen it yet
this is when she brings up the
friendship and I think again because
maybe because you had a high friendship
rating kind of Allah mass effect or
something he saved you here I don't know
you actually would died partner or died
right there but he's [ __ ] smokes dude
when comes back um we're about to see
kind of how the strongholds can change
based on the enemies and a little bit
but sure but they won Bagheera system
there were a aesthetic new outfit but
you just got this like row Hyrum outfit
would look so [ __ ] sick oh my gosh
watch your lorry I know I'm like it
looks kinda like you're like buddy
Brenda the man on his face can we get a
more interesting looking person no I did
not only not like are gonna ask guy no
no it's just so plain I can't be the
only one who looks at that and I'm like
that's the most generic face etre I
probably caught that back in 2014
oh you guys are on love no I don't know
necessarily like it I just keep thinking
about how funny is to imagine like this
guy this human hanging out with orcs day
and night making friends I'd get pretty
frustrated I'm probably like I like it
we're all the like stress wrinkled ah
yeah
gray hair he's like a human people are
bringing up the swear jar I'll put money
into it after the show ends we have to
bring it back to keep us up you just
give me this um yeah but the Kirra
system is actually affecting your
abilities now but here's this do the
demolisher he's not immune to fire which
I say that specifically because you get
onto a warg soon right here and when
you're mounted you are but you're
demolisher he's dead
I like sit down like like God great I
got to find another troll right but your
other lieutenant that they brought they
showed at the beginning which this
becomes important later on the demo he's
immune to fire and if you guys saw in
the menu when you were when they were
planning on attacking the stronghold it
showed that the boss has like flame
attacks and weapons that comes into play
here but also you can see something
about to happen right here so you cannot
just ride wargs you can ride and we'll
for again dragon this looks like lair do
you remember that yeah this is not too
much in common but just like the dragon
mechanics look similar sorts enough yeah
this looks really fun I mean yeah I
dragon what else so I can
he's just raining down fire like imagine
like if the witch King comes at you on
his novel and you're just in an aerial
battle kind of like a Dragonball Z thing
between a wyvern and that veteran reach
that like yeah we got the boss battle
coming up but yeah I'm interested in how
this game is going to combine the
open-world and combat mechanics with the
overarching strategy layer because they
kind of describe it but they don't
really show it in execution too much
they say that once you take over this
fortress you will that fortress will be
the hub for that region and it'll be
depending on the Overlord you put in
place to govern it that'll he'll dictate
whether you get new recruits for your
army or new supplies or maybe like new
war machines but here you see he's about
to take over this - GOG guy with it he's
freaking out because you just showed up
on a dragon and you're controlling mine
so you get him and yeah yeah it's no
problem I'm on your side yeah cool it
could you do its elemental my eye hahaha
so now he's just recruited him he's
gonna help fight for you all of a sudden
and of course now you're coming up to
the final Overlord and boss battle which
is pretty cool this shows how the
Nemesis system affects the stronghold
soon and slow walking yeah I would I
never loved Foley in video I really hope
compare the first game that there is a
lot more diversity and terrain and
areas opposed to what the first can just
had like - you know I've had like the
typical igneous rock of Mordor and that
kind of lush region yeah but barely
barely yet so here we go again the
narrator's talking about how depending
on what overlord there is this boss
fight arena will be different this
dude's a versus fire attacks and
obviously you could see he's this
massive troll but he's got these like
two podiums neither serve two pillars on
either side of them that become these
flamethrowers but this boss fight plays
out differently depending on their
preferences and their ability so the
students is very much into like flame
based combat so that factors into this
boss fight arena which is super cool
because that actually affects the
stronghold not just the characters I
really want to know how many strongholds
yeah being a single playthrough how
limited is it or yeah I mean because if
this is like you know generated through
like Street algorithm or whatever and
there's like a lot of them like this is
really impressive but I have to imagine
that outside of the boss arenas a lot of
these are going to have to be handmade
yeah unless they somehow manage to
generate them Randy so they do in the in
for the first game I definitely I forgot
at what point but toward the later parts
of the game I was seeing like similar
guys Oh as far as Warchief yeah like now
you wait I've seen you before
sort of like to find enough variables
that the game's doesn't really yeah have
any grounds um yeah and that was like
you know a little not just hardening but
it was like hey wait I can I kill you
and you're back yeah um so I'm
interested to see how they do that
because again they're they talk about
each work Warchief having a different
story right bring the road like story to
the table like emergent gameplay as it
were yeah I'm curious know to what
extent will that be right yeah earlier
today Grant Wilson on Twitter was saying
do you think shadow war risks alienating
players the first game with this new
tower defense style fortress system I
don't think it's like Howard offense but
I get what he's saying that's kind of
what I was just wondering how much like
the first game would be if you liked it
with the open-world in the combat like
how is it going to factor into this
overarching strategy layer because they
show how it implements into the combat
but they don't show too much of the
actual strategy
like UI and whatnot we got two fans
right right here I mean would you want a
second game that was functionally
similar to the first one and yeah just
the narrative being different I mean I
would like that but no I like I think
reality would rob you and I were talking
about yesterday the seems like it's like
a full-on
sequel in the sense that it's you know
changing things up so right I don't I
think it risks alienating players in the
first game but I'm excited for it as a
huge fan of the first game that was my
game of the era 2014 I'm really excited
for this even outside like the Lord of
the Rings fan service I can't wait that
seems like again XCOM who is one of my
favorite games last year and this isn't
a turn-based strategy game but there's
still that dichotomy between the
strategy and the actual up close action
which really excites me I can't think of
a game that that had a similar like
region control mechanic of where God and
knowing in this game I'm speaking of is
all great my fortress is being attacked
again so I have to fall back to this
fortress and dagger bend it when I'm
already trying to advance in discovering
or exploration like max know I know what
you're talking about I did was this game
I can't think of it was like a UK I had
to go back and defend it
there was an assassin's Creed there
wasn't a discrete games did that
Assassin's Creed 4 Black Flag you kind
of came up on stronghold like this but
then in like earlier and I think
Brotherhood or revelations was the RET
it was revelations I'm thinking of when
you have to do that tower defense stuff
and it was awful but after a while you
realize you don't even need to worry
about the right round holds but that's
what I'm thinking of at least and and
here they're talking about you know you
would point this guy here who is what
his stronghold perk is that he will
pillage the area and bring in more
resources so it's I have to like you
know I mean like it might intake of
resources is now being diminished
because I have to go back and like you
know defend this get like castle I'm
being distracted and I don't know if I
want so much for that one in the chat
might just fall out for yeah I think I
might add almost how often how how often
they would pop up and I would say forget
it yeah you just you're so rude right
forget it
sorry I do
my part I'm a lone wanderer Alec Brenner
earlier on Twitter also had a question
yes if we think expanding on Nemesis
system is enough as a general gameplay
doesn't seem too altered based on the
depth they're going for with this or
would it appear they're going for and
this game what releases in August right
I'm really far out it's yeah dude it's
what kind of close to five months away
yeah six months away
yeah super excited for this game I think
there looks like they're doing enough to
make it I got an actual sequel not just
like a narration on the first game yeah
I'm for yeah I mean it makes sense like
the last game like you you know you
built your army he did you know just a
minimal attack with them and here it's
like hey you still have this army that
you just you know yeah create it and now
you're like waging war shadow war yes
I'm super excited for this game you
haven't lost it yet we have that 60
minute gameplay video up on GameSpot I
encourage you to go watch it you just
saw entirety of it we just watched we
watched a lot of quite a lot of it but
yeah you can see how attacking these
strongholds works you go watch the
entire gameplay video we do have kind of
we had a lot of segments a couple weeks
ago about what we want it but now we
know much more about the game you want
to go back 2014 and read a review I
don't know who reviewed that game maybe
it was Kevin fan or one he did was yeah
shadow of Mordor is worth getting back
into if like you have a lull from zelda
or near or Mass Effect which is coming
out in a couple weeks go try a shadow of
Mordor out highly encourage it but other
than that let us know what you think of
the sixty minutes a gameplay if you're
as excited as Rob and I are and Pete
basically you saw not anyway we're in
too much specifically no no okay so let
us know you
[Music]
you